Even when you look at the scripture, it
calls Satan the god of this world. So
Satan in his term is a
Christ is al Christ is a god to us, but
he's not a god to the father.
>> Then why does the father call him god?
>> Father, father, son, holy spirit.
>> Why does the father why does the father
call him god?
>> Because when you look at the word god,
obviously you've done this in the strong
concordance, you will see that god has
so many different representations. And
that's where people make a mistake.
>> Do you see what I'm saying? Because
>> I'm not talking about
>> like you said angels, judges.
>> Yeah. I'm not I'm not talking about See,
notice what happened.
>> You said Christ is a god to us, but not
a god to the father, but the father
calls him god.
>> Right. And now you're saying, well,
>> this this just is in a generic sense
that even Satan or angels or human
judges are called gods. That's what
you're saying.
>> Yeah. But the context tells us
different. You would agree that the
context will tell us when the word god
is used whether it's meaning in a in a
generic type of way in a role or
whatever or whether it's talking about
in their essence as the true god, right?
Context will tell us that, right?
>> Yeah. Okay. Context. Yeah. Cont. Yeah.
Context when you read the scripture will
tell you what they're what they're
speaking about. So in the context in
which the father calls the son god in
Hebrews 1:8 in that context he continues
to go on and say and you lord so there's
a father speaking of the son
>> you lord
>> laid the foundation of the earth and the
heavens are the works of your hands
>> they will perish but you remain they
will wear out like a garment but your
years will have no end so he's
glorifying ing the Son as the Lord who
created all things and who is
unchanging.
Does that sound like anything less than
the most high God to you?
>> Yeah, because I think you can't just use
one scripture to just justify and say
that
>> that's that's a whole context. The whole
chapter look
I'm talking about Hebrews 1, bro.
Hebrews 1, that was that was verses 10
to 12. Verse 8, he calls him God. verse
10 to 12, he calls him the Lord who
created all things and who will never
change and who commanded all things and
how the heavens and the earth are the
work of his hands.
>> Um in verse 1 and two it says that he's
the son of the father who through whom
all things were made
>> and how it was through him that even the
times were created, the ages were
created
>> and that by the at the word of his power
the universe is sustained.
Yeah.
>> And then says that he is the exact
imprint of the father's nature, bro.
>> And I love that exact imprint. He didn't
say he is the father. Exact imprint,
>> which means that he's which means he's
not the father.
>> He's not the person of the father, but
he has the same nature as the father.
The exact nature that the father has,
Jesus has as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Which gohead.
>> Yeah. So even with you saying that point
I agree with you but the main thing is
exact imprint. Remember when Christ left
he says that you will do greater things
than I have done. I have given you this
power. So Christ has given us that power
as well to do certain to do certain
things as well.
>> Yeah. But you got to look at the context
of greater given Christ power.
>> No no no.
>> Christ has given us power.
>> No. He's not saying that he's giving
that we're going to be doing greater
works in quality but in quantity be and
look the context is him going away. He
says I'm going away. I'm going back to
my father.
>> But those who believe will do the same
works that I do and even greater works
will he do than these
>> because I'm going to my father.
>> So they're gonna they're going to do
more than he did. Not better than what
he did. They're just going to do more.
They're going to do the same things he
did, but more of it. Quantity, not
quality. Make sense?
>> Okay. Yeah, I can agree with that.
>> Okay. So, but with Jesus, he then goes
on to say things like,
"Whoever asks in my name,
>> I will do it. Truly I tell you, whoever
asks me in my name, I will do it." So he
goes on to say how while he's away with
the father, we can supplicate to him,
call out to him, pray to him, and not
only can we pray to him, but he's going
to answer our prayer. He will answer us.
He has the ability to do it. And then he
says, it's whatever you ask in my name
that I will do. So in asking in his
authority, addressing him in his
authority, and he will do it. What kind
of qualities do you have to have, Nash,
to be able to do whatever it is that
your believer asks to be able to hear
all believers everywhere at the same
time, multiple places, all at once, and
to be able to meet every believer
wherever they are to answer their prayer
wherever they are. What kind of
attributes do you have to have to have
these abilities?
>> Christ, he says that I will do Christ.
Yeah, you have to be a God to do that.
You have to have a god-like energy to do
that. 100%.
He's not the most high God. He even says
it in the scripture.
>> No, brother.
>> Can I show you? Can I show you a
scripture?
>> I'm listening. Go ahead, man.
>> All right. There's so many scriptures.
Um,
>> even if you go to John 14,
>> you're justifying polytheism for me,
bro.
>> No, I'm not I'm not saying that. I'm not
saying that. Oh, I'm just saying that
Christ is God, but he's not the most
high God.
>> He's a lesser God than the most high
God, but he's he's a God. He's the high
priest as Hebrews tells us. He's the
high priest and the mediator.
>> No one can get to the father unless they
go through him. So, there's a
differentiation.
>> So, you have the father,
>> Christ, and God.
>> So, you have the father who's the most
high god and you have the son who's a
lesser god.
>> How many gods is there?
>> I didn't say the son I didn't say the
son's a lesser god. I said the I think
you're just I I know the way you're
trying to word it and I get I get where
you're coming from. If you want to say
it like that, we can say it like that.
Son is the lesser god. If you want to
say it like that, that's totally fine.
But the scripture refers to him as a
high priest and a mediator. Nobody can
go to the father unless they go through
the son. So there's a clear between the
father and the son.
>> I got you. How many gods is that when
you have the most high and the lesser
god? How many is that?
>> Christ is the son of god but he's a god
to us.
>> So how many is that?
>> How many gods?
>> Mhm.
>> When you say what in terms of there's
two. You're saying if you want to put it
that way you can say two. That's how
people understand.
>> Is that monotheism or poly is that
monotheism or polytheism or
>> that's polytheism.
>> So you're a polytheist.
>> I'm not saying okay if you if you want
what I'll say is if you want to put it
in that context.
>> Not not if I want to put it there. I I I
don't I don't want to put it there. But
that's where if we got if we're honest
and consistent that's where your
position leads us. You are a polytheist.
It's as simple as that. And you're
trying to justify it with scripture.
There's only one God and that is the
most high.
>> No, there's not. There's another God, a
lesser God, Jesus Christ. According to
you,
>> the son of God according to the
scripture of God. If you want a lesser
god,
>> if we want to use English and and refer
to him, how we want to refer to him.
Yes, we can say there's two gods. If
that's easier for people to comprehend
logic, then I'll run with that. But
>> that's not But that's just your
position. You got to be honest with your
position, though. I don't you're not
you're not being completely honest with
your position. Your your position is a
polytheistic position. You're going
against the Bible.
>> Yes. My No, my position is the fact that
Christians say Christ is God. I don't
agree with that.
>> So you disagree with the father?
>> The father hasn't said. Okay. Can I can
I read the scripture just what I what
I've read to understand it? Yeah. You
about to read John 14:28.
>> There's loads of them, you know. There's
John Yeah, there's John 14:28.
There's Luke 1:32.
>> Let's go one Let's go one by one. Let's
go one by one. You just said John 14:28.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, okay, I can read that.
So, ye have heard how I said unto you, I
go away and come again unto you. If you
loved me, ye would rejoice because I
said, I go unto the Father, for my
father is greater than I. So Christ has
made a clear differentiation within that
scripture that the father is greater
than I. He could have just said I am
greater. But why did he put the father
there? So that's one of the scriptures.
I don't know.
>> Let's go ahead and break this down. Why
why would they be happy that he's going
to somebody greater than him?
>> I'm I'm not looking at the whole context
of the scripture. I'm just looking at
>> I I know I know you're not looking at
it.
>> Yeah. So start from just in the verse.
Why would they be happy
>> that he's going to someone greater to
the father who's greater than him? Why?
Why should they be happy about that?
>> Why should who be happy? The apostles.
>> Mhm.
>> Or who people I mean Yeah.
>> Notice how he starts it off. You should
be glad that I'm going away cuz I'm
going away to my father. You should be
happy for me. Why would they be happy
for him that he's going to the father
who's greater than him?
Um, I'll say if you can answer it. If
you have the answer, please just Yeah.
>> Because he's going back to a status that
he had before coming down in flesh.
Remember how you said the father stayed
in heaven but the son came down.
>> Yeah.
>> That's that coming down is humility.
That's him humbling himself, taking the
role of that servant. However, when he
goes back to the father, he's being
exalted back again to that status and
with that and that glory that he once
had before he came down. It's being
returned to him. That's why they should
be happy for him. For the father is
greater than I. Not in quality, not in
nature, but in the status of their
roles. The father is greater than him
because he's the servant of the father.
>> Okay. So, you look at as more of a role
perspective.
>> Of course.
>> That's what that is. Cuz remember I you
know the verses that I just quoted for
you about uh you know them doing greater
works. Remember greater works
>> not in quality but in quantity.
>> All of that's that's that's John 14.
That's just a few verses before that's
John 14 12-4 where Jesus talks about how
we can pray to him. He'll answer us and
he's able to answer us. Meaning that
he's all powerful. He's all knowing and
he's not limited to space.
So he has all the he has the omni
properties that make God what God is.
>> Yeah.
>> So he has the same nature as the father
>> just a he's a distinct person who op has
a different operation than the father.
He's not the person of the father but as
he's demonstrating even in John 14 that
he has the same nature as the father
>> which means that he also is the most
high god along with the father.
[Music]
Okay. So if he has that energy why does
he sit on the right hand side of the
father? Because again, he was exalted
up. He humbled himself and remains
humble. He's exalted up and sits and
rules at the father's right hand still
as the mediator and high priest for us.
He's still in that position of humility
to the father. Still, it never stops.
Okay?
>> But he still knows where he is ruling at
the right hand of the father. that equal
power.
>> So you think he has equal power to the
father?
>> Yes,
>> absolutely. There's nothing that the
father can do, right? In regards to like
um you know supernatural
divine acting properties, right? That
the son can't do. creation, salvation,
um you know, whatever you could think
of, inspiration, revelation,
visions, dreams, uh you know, calling
and sending prophets.
>> But that doesn't make him the most high
just because he can do those things.
>> Yes, it does. The fact that he can cuz
only the most high can do those things,
bro. only
>> what in terms of what you mentioned I
think obviously in terms of creation yes
I I'd agree with that I think that's the
only exception but there are other gods
as well when you look at the scripture
it tells us that every nation has their
gods
>> they are false gods though
>> yeah they're false gods but some of
these false gods
>> for example some of these prophets can
see things psychics mediums but they're
not of the most high's
army so they can still do those things
and pretend but they are not of the most
high status.
>> Yeah, these are these are these aren't
gods at all. These aren't gods. These
are false gods. Demons in action. Even
the Bible talks about uh that these are
manifestations of demons, you know, and
evil spirits. Okay.
>> But as far as the operations of the true
God, only he can create,
>> right? Only he can give other people
ability to do miracles of like creating
raising life. Only God can do that. Only
God can forgive sins or give somebody
the permission to forgive sins. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Only God can do that. Those things these
are things Jesus does.
>> So why why do you feel like the
scripture in so many verses has
differentiated the father from the son
to us? because
>> because you're not you're not hearing
what I'm saying. It's uh they're one in
one sense and distinct in another. And
what does that mean?
The distinction
>> Okay. So
>> is between their personhood. They're not
the same person. That's why you see a
differentiation between the father and
the son. The father who begets the son,
the son who's begotten of the father,
the father who sends the son, the son
who does the work of the father, the son
who glorifies the father and the father
glorifies the son. Right? You you see
this interaction and distinction between
the two persons. However,
when you jump on the other side, there
is a oneness, a un a unity in their
essence where they are not divided. They
are indivisible in their essence.
They're not separated. They're not
separated at all. There's they're
they're the same one being.
However, they are distinct in their
personhood. Not separate, but distinct.
>> Okay. Um
>> that's Bible, man.
>> Can we look at um a few more verses or
Sure. Well,
>> John 5:26.
>> Okay. For the father has granted him For
the father has life in himself and has
granted the son to also have life in
himself.
>> Exactly. So the father is the one who
granted life to the son.
>> Beautiful.
>> So again we see that distinction between
the father and the son. And if you look
at it the father's called depending on
how you say some people say Yahweh some
say Yahawah.
>> The son is called Yahweh too. We could
get there. We'll get there after John
5:26. I'll show you that the son is
called Yahweh. Okay.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, John John 5:26. I I love
John 5. Have you you've read John 5 in
its context? Yeah.
>> Not in its context. I just have a lot of
precepts that differentiate the father
from the sons. So, I I've read it, but I
haven't read it now. Like, I'm not
>> Got it.
>> Yeah. I've read it before.
>> So, Jesus makes sure makes it known even
though there's a distinction between him
and the father, there's no separation.
And Jesus is the be the one who's
begotten, right? He's the begotten of
the father, meaning that he is brought
forth eternally from the father's
essence. That's an eternal action. It
doesn't happen in time. There's no
beginning of this action or end. But the
son is eternally begotten of the father.
So because the father is the head or
source of the divine essence and he's
the one who begets the son because the
father has life in himself and the son
is begotten from the father's having the
same essence as the father. This way
that life is also communicated to the
son. He grants the son to have life in
himself.
So both the father and the son have life
in him in themselves. They're the source
of the life right? They are independent.
They're they're not created. However,
the source the the source of that life
is from the father. It's being
communicated to the son and the spirit.
>> So this isn't this isn't talking about
creation.
>> Okay?
>> So notice like in this cont in what
Jesus is saying as the father has life
in himself. So the son has life. He has
granted the son to have life in himself.
Meaning that the son in himself is the
source of life also. Right? However, he
has that or that comes from the father
that's communicated to him from the
father.
>> And then the last, let's go for one more
scripture and
uh revelations 3:21.
>> Okay.
Yeah. Um, to him that overcomemeth will
I grant to sit with me in my throne even
as I also overcame and I'm set down with
my father in his throne. Again, you see
the differentiation there.
>> My father and the son.
>> Again, no problem. They're distinct
persons.
>> Do you do you understand? Do you
understand my position?
>> I I get your position. I I get I totally
I understand where your but I think when
people say Jesus is God
>> it's just to put him on the same level
as the father is what I can't comprehend
>> the father does it
>> the father does that look look for
example go to um you're in the Bible
right
>> go to um go to Psalm 83 Three.
[Music]
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Psalm 83
verse 18.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. What does it say?
that men may know that thou
whose name alone is
Jehovah the most high over all the
earth.
>> Mhm. The most high over all the earth.
Alone. There's only one that's Jehovah.
Right now, here's another one.
>> Read Psalms. We're going to stay in
Psalm for a little bit.
>> Go to Psalm
>> chapter uh uh 89.
>> Yeah. Read verse uh read verse six
there.
>> For who for who in heaven can be
compared unto the Lord? Who among the
sons of the mighty can be likened unto
the Lord? Yeah.
>> All right. Remember these remember
these. Who uh who alone is the one who's
the most high over all the earth? That's
Yahweh. Who alone is the most high over
all the earth. And this one just said,
"Who in the heavens, who in the skies,
who in the heavens can be compared to to
him?" Right. To Yahweh. Yeah. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Um like who among the sons of God are
like him, right?
>> Yes. Yep.
>> Okay. And then here's one more. Go to
chapter 113. Psalm 113
verse 5.
Yeah. Who? Yeah. Perfect. Who is like
unto the Lord our God and who dwelleth
on high?
>> And what's the answer to that?
>> I think a lot of the scriptures that you
just p pulled up here is kind of
pointing to the most high being the most
high.
>> Yep. It's point it's pointing to the
most high being the most high and
unique, right? There's nobody like him.
None of the sons of God can be compared
to him or like him.
>> And only the most high sits on high.
>> Right.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
>> All right.
>> Yeah. I'm with you on that.
>> Now, do me this favor,
>> cuz the answer to this, watch this.
>> Yeah.
>> If if if we're going with yours with
your ideology, with your theology, we're
going to have a problem
>> because Go to Hebrews chapter one.
Read verse three.
Yet who being the brightness of his
glory and the express image of his
person and upholding all things by the
word of his power when we when he had by
himself purged our sins sat down on the
right hand of the majesty on high.
>> Wait, so where is Jesus sitting?
>> On the right hand side.
>> On high, right?
>> Of the It says right hand of the majesty
on high. So he's on high. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. He's on high but on the right hand
side.
>> Correct.
>> But notice remember
>> who is the only one who sits on high?
Who's the only one?
>> The Most High sits on high. Yeah.
>> Yahweh.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So if only Yahweh, Jehovah, if he's the
only one who sits on high, yet we see
that it's the father and the son both
sitting on high. It's either one or one
or two uh two one of two conclusions.
One
both the father and the son together are
Jehovah, the most high together.
Or
we got ourselves a contradiction.
There's somebody else, a creature, a
lesser being than the most high who's
also sitting on high with the most high
and therefore contradicting the
scripture and committing blasphemy here.
[Music]
So either
>> you you see what I'm saying?
>> Nobody, the scripture is clear. Nobody
else other than Jehovah sits on high
yet. And nobody can be compared to
Jehovah. None of the sons of God are
like Jehovah. But according to Hebrews
1:3, we see all of those things. Jesus
is the express image of his nature of
his person. Right? That means he's
exactly like the father. Correct?
>> So he's exactly like the father.
>> When the scripture says there's no one
like Jehovah, Jesus is exactly like
Jehovah. The scripture says there's none
in the heavens that can be compared to
him. Yet Jesus is in the heavens who is
exactly like Jehovah. There's nobody
other than the most high sits on high
above all the earth and creation. Where
is Jesus sitting? On high with the
father.
>> Yeah, he's sitting on high with the
father,
but he's on the other he's on the right
hand side of the father.
>> Which is equality. Which is an equality.
>> And okay. Um and your point is what
you're pointing to God logic. You're
saying that
because he sits on high with the father,
the father's given him dominion over the
world, right? Can we agree on that? He's
given him dominion over the world. And
Christ also gave us that as well. He
gave us dominion as well.
>> Yeah. But do you still
>> RV? It says the son shows the glory of
God. He is a perfect copy of God's
nature and he holds everything together
by his powerful command
>> and sits at the right hand of the
majesty on high.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's either
>> people
>> either you got a contradiction, bro. And
there is somebody that sits on high with
the most high. There is somebody that
can be compared to the most high. There
is somebody that who's most high over
all the earth with the most high. Either
you got these this is a contradiction or
You go with the scripture, the flow of
the scripture and acknowledge it what
it's saying about Jesus that he yours is
the most high as well with the father.
>> Your psalm scripture yours your psalm
scripture that you brought up wouldn't
you say contradicts that the scriptures
that you brought before going to Hebrews
because it was clear that your scripture
said that there is one Jehovah
and he's on top, right? He's on high.
One Jehovah.
The one Jehovah exists, bro, as three
distinct persons. That's the point.
>> Jehovah is not just one person. Jehovah
is the father, the son, and the holy
spirit.
>> The one Jehovah, the one divine essence
exists as three persons.
That's the point.
And then my last my last question um is
also what's your issue with the he with
the Israelites in terms of
>> is what is what I asked you it's I have
my my issue is with the one west
ideology
>> that
>> oh okay
>> that only that only Gentiles can be
saved or can't be saved. That's my
issue.
>> You believe that the the Negroes are the
Hebrews?
>> No, some of them not all of them.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. So, you're unbelief
for that. Okay. Perfect. That's that's
totally fine. Thank you for your time.
Appreciate you. Um and I'll I'll dwell
on those scriptures.
>> Yeah. Look look into this, man. This is
serious. This is serious.
>> Yeah, I've been looking into it. I think
it's my second conversation with you to
be fair. So, I'm just I'm always
>> looking into it. So, yeah. Appreciate
you. Thank you, my brother.
>> Take care, man.
>> All right.